if I wear what is comfortable the legs
how much less powerful redefining and
not her responsibility what is your
opinion of me
my response Billy Eilish undresses while
calling out body shamers well you've
never seen my pad in her new powerful
short film called not my responsibility
the singer addressed people's unwelcomed
opinions about her sense of style and
body image
some people had whatever some people
praised it
some people use it to shame puzzles some
people use it to shame me
throughout the video Billy slowly
removes the layers of her signature
oversized look while diving further into
the criticism would you like me to be
quiet to my shoulders provoke you does
my chest and my stomach the body I was
appointment is not what she wanted in
the monologue Billy says quote we make
assumptions about people based on their
size we decide who they are we decide
what they're worth the 18 year old then
strips down to her bra and goes into a
pool of black liquid if I were more if I
wear that
who decides what that makes me fans
totally recognized the short film Billie
originally unveiled the video during her
concert in March if I think too hard I
get all up in my head so don't ever
think it Billie has been very open about
her body image in the past she explained
in a Calvin Klein commercial why she
wears oversized clothing I never want
the world to know everything about me I
mean that's why I wear big baggy clothes
nobody can have an opinion because they
haven't seen what's underneath you know
but those opinions still come and have
affected her life a lot as she told ABC
breakfast I mean it's insane that I even
have been reading comments up until this
point I should have stopped long ago the
internet is ruined every ruining my life
so I turned it off Billy hopes to
inspire her fans through fashion and
music people coming up to you asking
about your style is that weird that
people are so intrigued and interested
it's it's really sick it's kind of
exactly what I would want people to care
about you know like I don't know the
things that people sort of know me for
or all the things
if that makes sense concil has always
been something I care about you know
visuals and videos and you know designs
and stuff is also something and you know
those are the things people sort of ask
me about or compound is really grateful
for them
[Music]